hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to reduce
bloating quickly if you're bloating
not only does it look like you have
belly fat but it's very uncomfortable
it prevents sleeping and you can't fit
in your clothes so there's some real
simple things you can do number one
acupressure
acupressure is basically you're pressing
instead of using needles you're pressing
on different parts of your body
now the where you want to press is you
want to press underneath your right rib
cage
right here take your hand and press into
it and hold that for
two minutes what are you doing you're
kind of massaging your
your gallbladder and that will help
reduce all that congestion in there and
you'll you'll feel less bloated because
the gallbladder stores something called
bile bile
and that's really what's helps you
digest the fats and if you're deficient
in bile
or it's the gallbladder sluggish you
will get bloating when you eat okay
then you want to press on the other side
right through in here because you got
the gallbladder on the right side
on the left side you have the pancreas
so the pancreas
is the other digestive gland that helps
you make the
enzymes to digest all these foods so
every time you eat your body
your pancreas senses what you eat and it
generates certain enzymes to help break
that down
so if you run out of certain enzymes
you're going to get bloated because the
pancreas is not doing its job
and you're going to feel just bloated so
you want to work on the left side as
well
so you have two minutes in the right two
minutes on the left boom you feel less
bloated
but but of course we want to fix
the diet because this is only temporary
the next time you eat comes right back
so this gives you temporary relief and
now we want to avoid the true
deeper root causes of bloating the the
common ones are the grains and that
would be the breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes
sodas juice alcohol things like that the
sugars
but especially gluten gluten is in the
it's the protein in the grain
it just creates a lot of bloating for
people and then
people say i'm gluten free but you're
still doing the grains so they do tend
to create bloating
now sugars especially combined with
protein
so if you're doing some hamburger
with the bun and the fries
and the soda or the hot dog with the bun
you know and the carbs oh my gosh you
are going to get a massive
spike of insulin and massive bloating so
let's say you go to a chinese restaurant
what do you get
sweet and sour chicken which is breaded
so anything that you combine protein in
sugar is really really bad for bloating
and then also like what about all the
bars like the energy bars or protein
bars
what do they have in them sugars so you
want to read labels and make sure that
you just keep the sugars to a zero a
minimum
and and that's really the danger of the
combination
and also fat with sugar will really
increase insulin too
more than eating them separate so that
would be like
let's say you have a donut that's deep
fried or some deep fried
i don't know french fry they coat it
with sugar but mainly the the donut
i will guarantee if you have a
deep-fried donut that's all the sugar
and fat and it's sweet and it's it's
oily and you eat that you're going to
bloat i guarantee that's going to happen
so and the starches so we got the the
rice
potato things like that those are foods
that will bloat you
and of course you can do too much
protein as well so
again we want to reduce those common
things and then at the same time
let's say you reduce them and you still
have a problem then we have to increase
your acid in your stomach
especially if you have acid reflux why
because acid reflux is
caused by not enough acid and people are
taking anti-acids oh my gosh they just
screw everything up
so we want to increase the acid we want
to increase the bile bile
which helps you digest fat so the way i
do it is i use the apple cider vinegar
plus this has something called a
concentrated
apple cider vinegar tablet so you can
swallow it before a meal like two to
three before meal and it has something
else called betaine hydrochloride
which basically builds up your acids in
your stomach
okay so this is really important and
then the gallbladder formula this has
some purified bile salts you take it
after you eat just one
take two or three before one after
it's just gonna help you and then the
bile also has in there a lot of other
things says enzymes
it has things to help the gallbladder
and it's a combination that is really
good for bloating
to correct the problem a lot of people
are happy with that so
so yes we want to give you some
temporary relief we want to change the
diet
and we might need to use nutrition if it
doesn't go away all right
i will see you in the next video